If somebody said, "Hey, I have a problem
with black people."
and then started jumping into crime
rates, that would be exactly the same
thing as what he just did.
>> Wow, this one's going to follow him for
a while, you guys. That is a wild thing
to say.
Your dead friend doesn't mean you can't
criticize him or judge him because he he
did it to figure out his head, figure
out his life. So, brand new Hasan
banger, guys.
Brand new Hasan banger. Everyone's upset
over this Hasan clip. Let's take a look
and figure out why.
So, he's responding to a chatter
when he when he says this.
>> 15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining or
did IEDs explode them for you, dumbass?
Shut the [__] up talking about Islam.
You are an infinitely bigger terrorist
than any random Muslim ever could be.
Dumbass.
Shut your ass up. Go enjoy your PTSD,
[__] [__] you. Imagine having the
audacity to be like, "Yeah, I went to
Iraq. I went to Iraq and it's actually
Islam that's the biggest danger. You're
the danger, idiot."
You're a danger to your family
and a danger to yourself, douchebag.
Lol, that's getting clipped, Lamah. I
don't give a [__] dude. Shut the [__]
up. If you go to Iraq and you learn that
lesson, you realize that that was wrong,
you're welcome here. You come back from
Iraq and you [__] talk about how this
was actually awesome and I hate Islam,
then [__] you. You didn't learn
anything. You're goddamn cattle. You're
sending other people like you to be in a
similar predicament to yourself.
Whatever, [__] I'll start live
streaming on YouTube tomorrow. Suck my
dick. Now you're getting clipped.
By who? The people that have been
literally begging for American sons and
daughters to go and die in Iran for the
last 2 weeks? By people who keep going,
"Yeah, based. No, we got to give more
money to Israel."
Those people?
>> I'm sorry. This is just an appropriate
energy to have right now. I'm sorry, it
just is. This is the appropriate level
of energy to have
for someone coming into your chat saying
I was in Iraq
Islam
Iran, you know, operation W.
This is the appropriate energy to bring
to that person.
>> People who are going to turn around and
then now act as though they give a
about veterans
the same people like Asmongold who
celebrated when that Navy SEAL
uh with his with his uniform had his arm
broken?
Really? That's what we're doing? If
Twitch can apply this double standard
when one veteran is getting their arm uh
broken
by an American congressperson for
opposing America waging Israel's wars.
When Twitch doesn't ban Asmongold for
laughing at that and saying yeah, based
and that he deserved it. When Twitch
literally doesn't say a single damn
thing about that but then turns around
and tries to ban me for this
this platform, I will never come back
here.
Y'all are a bunch of dumb
too for being like, "Oh, you're going to
get clipped."
>> He goes off on Twitch when they didn't
even do anything yet.
Yeah, but I honestly wonder like I feel
like he they risk your ban with this
clip a little bit. I honestly wonder
whether that gave him a bit more
protection where they're going off like
that and bringing up the double standard
at the time. Always gives him a bit of a
buffer.
You know?
Cuz they they do they do just hit Hasan
now. They do hit him. They're only hit
him for like a day.
It's not like he's getting like big
bans.
But they do just hit him now just to be
like, "Look, we're doing something.
We're doing something."
>> Some [__]
doesn't even realize his own lived
experiences should have taught him a
very valuable lesson.
>> We had we had this discussion last night
about whether veterans should be a
protected class. And it makes total
sense for like a lot of things,
especially when like we said we had when
you had the draft, like you didn't want
like it caused problems with in society
if you could turn like huge swaths of
the population down based on veteran
status for jobs and [__] like that.
So there is there are reasons to have it
as a protected class.
But uh it certainly shouldn't be treated
the same as being like black, you know.
You chose to do it and got a lot of
benefits from it.
It was a job that you picked. So nothing
really uh controversial about that clip
in my opinion. I understand Some Some
people may disagree, I know.
Some uh young lads may disagree.
But uh not really anything controversial
or contestable about that clip. I think
that's totally reasonable. I think some
[__] [__] Iraq veteran Jesus
Christ my camera's frozen. Some [__]
[__] Iraq veteran coming into your
chat uh bragging about what they did,
crying about [__] Islam, talking
about how Islam is a big danger,
uh and supporting the Iran uh Operation
Epic Fury
uh is deranged and [__] and that
person deserves to have very rude things
said to them, tailored to them, because
they are a disgusting, lowlife
uh degenerate waste of space
who probably voted for some of the most
disgusting [__] to happen in the modern
world.
Uh
so totally reasonable from Hasan there,
in my opinion, in my humble opinion. And
the other thing, key thing here,
is it was targeted to that person. Hasan
did not say stuff about all veterans.
Hasan did not say hate to all veterans.
Hasan said
he hates veterans who support other
people getting put into the same
awful situations, doing horrible, [__]
up, illegal [__]
as they did. If you don't come away from
Iraq thinking that was bad, that
shouldn't happen again, then [__] you.
Then [__] you. That's not all veterans.
That's a set of people who did a set of
actions and have a set of beliefs. It's
not just all veterans. It's not just all
veterans. It's [__] [__] to
pretend it is.
So, let's take a look.
What sort of [__] [__]
What sort of absolute [__] idiot
zero
reading comprehension, zero critical
thought
[__] subhuman [__] fat [__]
would take that to be about all
veterans. I wonder.
Nicholas De Orio, come on down.
>> [laughter]
>> 3:17 is the timestamp we want here.
>> Already been community noted, but big
new Hasan clip dropping right now.
Enjoy it.
>> 15 years out from Iraq, eat my balls.
Do you even have your balls remaining,
or did a [__] IED explode them for
you, dumbass? Shut the [__] up talking
about Islam.
You are an infinitely bigger terrorist
than any random Muslim ever could be,
dumbass.
Shut your [__] ass up. Go enjoy your
[__]
>> It's funny that he throws the word
terrorist around when he cries like a
[__] that it's been used against him.
>> PTSD [__] [__] you. Imagine
>> Dude, they were saying terrorist in
their chat messages. He was saying who's
the terrorist? You're the terrorist. You
were in Iraq. You [__] idiot. He's
just got no idea what's going on. He's
got no This guy's talking about Islamic
terrorism. That's why he's always
bringing up terrorism, you [__]
idiot.
Dude, his coverage is so bad.
>> Imagine
Oh, the frogging line.
>> [__] PTSD [__] [__] you. Imagine
having the audacity to [__] be like
>> Yeah, exactly. The chat said it first.
>> I went to Iraq.
>> stupid.
>> And it's actually Islam that's the
biggest danger. You're the danger,
idiot.
You're a danger to your family.
And a danger to yourself, douchebag.
Lol, that's getting clipped. Lol, I
don't give a [__] dude. Shut the [__]
up. If you go to Iraq and you learn that
lesson, you realize that that was wrong.
>> The takeaway for this is that he just
hates veterans. That's the problem. Cuz
you can criticize what he said and fight
him on the like the actual talking
point.
>> Guys, he just hates veterans. That's why
he says there are plenty he's totally
fine with. That's why he's supporting a
veteran for office right now. That's why
he's supporting an ex-Blackwater
mercenary who defended Abu Ghraib prison
in Iraq, one of the most famous places
for human rights abuses in the entirety
of the the Iraq campaign.
Uh uh that Graham Plathner defended as a
mercenary guard uh
there at the place patrolling.
Stopping people breaking out or breaking
in.
And this guy supports him
for office.
But he hates vets, guys. He hates all
veterans. It's totally not about the
beliefs they hold, guys. It's It's about
their veteran status.
We can make this make sense somehow,
guys, if we just push this square peg in
that round hole hard enough.
>> What he's saying is [__] you, I hope you
get PTSD. You're a danger to your
family.
That's not applicable to the one chatter
cuz he doesn't know anything about the
chatter. The only
>> does. He knows the chatter is an Iraq
war vet who does not regret his service
and is saying deranged [__] about uh
Islam. That's what he knows. He knows
he's just some mentally unstable,
[__] vet with a bunch of stupid,
degenerate opinions that a bunch of
yankee degenerates have. And yankee
degenerates are often dangerous to their
family on their own because they love
owning guns and having mental
disabilities that they don't get
addressed for their entire [__] life.
Uh
American Marines are another level
because they have extra levels of
disability and love eating crayons.
Uh and they're all raped as children,
too.
And then they
>> [laughter]
>> grow up and they do crazy [__] in other
people's countries and they get mentally
ill and they don't get that addressed
and then they go home to their
government that doesn't give a [__]
about them and they rot on the street
and beat the [__] out of their wife if
they still have one who they they
probably cheated on them and left them
while they were serving. If they go back
to a wife, they go back to her and and
beat the [__] out of her and then they
have guns at home still and then they
end up using them on their family or
themselves.
That's
that's what Hassan's pulling on here is
the fact that this guy is some
lead-brained right-wing Yankoid
degenerate
uh who went to Iraq.
That's what he's drawing on here and
that's enough to know that they're at
they're at an elevated risk to their
family.
>> That's applicable is to like a
stereotype on actual veterans who've
seen conflict. Like it's just a like a
slap in the face to people who had
nothing to do with this conversation.
So, yeah, I understand
>> [laughter]
>> Wrong. You're welcome here. You come
back from Iraq and you [__] talk
about how this was actually awesome and
not [__] hate
>> Like the American sniper who was killed
by deranged Yankoid vet. Very true. By
and it was his own fault, too. Never let
them forget that, by the way, that that
big war hero, Chris Kyle,
uh got himself killed by his degenerate
friend
uh cuz he's a degenerate [__] [__]
Yankoid who thinks guns uh fix
everything. So, he took his degenerate
Yankoid vet friend to a shooting range
uh who had a PTSD meltdown and then shot
him
and uh and everyone else or the
instructor.
So,
uh great job great job American Army.
Great job American military.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> Mom, then [__] you. You didn't learn
>> You don't have to forget about the
reason why veterans are treated like
[__]
>> best commentator of the year.
>> They won't be in this case.
>> Can you imagine how funny it would be if
Hassan got drafted into WWE?
>> I know what will cheer you up.
>> No, he can't get
>> Chris Kyle Wikipedia page.
>> You know why? Cuz they updated it and
it's 25 and under. He's too old.
>> learn anything. You're goddamn cattle.
You're sending other people like you to
be in a similar [__] predicament to
yourself. Whatever, [__]
>> 25 and under, dude. All your favorite
YouTubers won't be drafted.
If the chatters go, the chatters go, you
know.
>> I'll start [__] live streaming on
YouTube tomorrow. Suck my dick. Now,
you're getting clipped.
By who? The people that have been
literally begging for American sons and
daughters to go and [__] die in Iran
for the last 2 weeks? By people who keep
going, "Yeah, based."
>> You can tell he realized
>> I notice it's not a bunch of you know,
British veterans going around online
saying we should be at war with Iran and
that
you know, Islam's like the the greatest
threat to to the globe right now.
I know it's not British veterans doing
that. Much saying the water over there.
Much saying the water over there.
>> As he [__] up here and he's like "I'll
just go stream on [__] YouTube, man."
>> No, we got to give more money to Israel.
Those people
those people who are going to [__]
turn around and then now act as though
they give a [__]
about veterans?
The same people like Asmongold who
[__] celebrated when that Navy SEAL
>> easy. Is a
>> uh with his with his uniform had his
[__] arm broken?
Really? That's what we're doing?
>> I don't even know what the [__] that's
about.
>> If Twitch can apply this [__] double
standard when one veteran is getting
their [__] arm uh broken by an
American congressperson for opposing
America waging Israel's war?
>> That's the thing, dude. I've met
I have met plenty of like military
fetishists
that
veered towards far right or straight-up
Nazi [__] Like I've told that story
about that that guy getting the SS book
in my old workplace.
I've met plenty of military fetishists
in the UK who veered towards being like
kind of, you know,
but I've never met an actual UK vet
who
uh veered towards that sort of stuff.
They're always pretty usually pretty,
you know,
at least uh center-right, you know.
They're usually kind of like Tory-ish,
you know. I I haven't met a whole bunch
of super far-right vets. Now, could be
limited experience. Could be limited
experience.
But it certainly seems worse for
America. It certainly American vets
certainly seem worse. I'm not going to
lie.
>> Cuz when Twitch doesn't
>> Now, I have heard I have had people I've
known about vets. I've had like mutual
friends and stuff like that.
Who I've heard stories about doing like
the whole,
you know, sort of bragging about
doing morally gray
uh crazy [__] in in uh Iraq Afghanistan.
I have heard that
through other people, but I've never
heard the actual beliefs
uh uh stated. I've never heard, you
know, quite as explicit.
>> [__] ban Asmongold for laughing at
that and saying, "Yeah, based."
>> Yeah, he just immediately pivoted from
being angry to like naming every single
person who can have also violated a
policy or making a hypocrisy hunt. He
realizes that his thing is like
he's mad at somebody, he goes after an
entire group of people. Obvious TOS
violation. But again, like if somebody
said, "Hey, I have a problem with black
people."
and then started jumping into crime
rates, that would be exactly the same
thing as what he just did.
>> Bro, what do you mean we fought like two
wars? We we we
Gulf War, Korean War, Falklands,
uh Iraq, Afghanistan,
Kosovo. We've been there with like all
the NATO
and US [__]
as well as our own [__]
>> I did. When Twitch literally doesn't
>> Israel made him break TOS, true?
>> say a single damn thing about that, but
then turns around and tries to ban me
for this [__] [__] this platform. I
will never [__] come back here.
Y'all are a bunch of dumb [__]
[__] too, for being like, "Oh,
you're going to get clipped."
>> It's a fair point. No, it's he's on the
back foot. He's just flailing.
This isn't like a point that he's
considered. He's throwing this out there
cuz he realized Well, he thinks he's
going to get banned. I don't think that.
Oh, here's the silence. Wait for it.
He's going to say
>> Dumb [__]
>> Yep.
>> Doesn't even realize his own lived
experiences should have taught him a
very valuable lesson.
>> Really? What if your lived experiences
taught you? What experience do you have?
Hassan violated Twitch's hateful con
duct and harassment poli
cy.
Veteran status is explicitly considered
a protected characteristic. Uh content
or be
behavior that attacks, harasses, and
promotes I mean, there's probably people
in his own audience that are veterans.
It doesn't mean that you're smart, but
you could be a Hassan [__] viewer or
whatever. I don't know.
It was just like a very pointed attack.
Not Sorry, not a very pointed It was a
very broad attack directly at veterans.
Oh, as for I don't know what this is.
This is the most hypocritical
>> the most hypocritical take ever.
Literally ever. I've never
>> Okay.
So, yeah, totally we're totally covering
that.
>> [clears throat]
>> We've got another banger though, guys,
okay? Just to throw in there.
Another banger reaction to this song
clip.
>> I think the odd bass
>> A fan favorite.
>> There's no way he actually said that,
right? 15 years old from Iraq, eat
balls.
>> dumb on purpose? Uh yes and no.
Yes and no.
Oz
>> Do you even have your balls remaining or
did a [__] IED explode them for you,
dumb?
>> Wow. Wow.
Wow. This one's going to follow him for
a while, you guys. That is a wild thing
to say.
That is a crazy thing to say. I am what
like what am I bro? Like one of my best
friends died from a [__] IED like
That is a wild thing to say, man.
>> Ozman, shut the [__] up talking about
Islam.
You are an infinitely bigger terrorist
than any random Muslim ever could be.
Dumbass.
Shut your [__] ass up. Go enjoy your
[__] PTSD, [__] [__] you.
>> Imagine Oh no. He I bet you anything he
knew he [__] up when he said that.
That's a crazy thing to say.
>> [laughter]
>> That's a crazy thing to say.
>> I went hard.
>> He's I I that's kind of crazy, man.
I I'll bet you anything a lot of
politicians are going to
hesitate
to collaborate with him now. I don't
know. It's just just from a practical
perspective, not even setting aside the
morality of it, but
just practically if he he's obviously
looking to expand his reach and make
connections and you know and collaborate
with politicians and
um he's been doing that more lately and
but saying stuff like that, that [__]
will make you so toxic.
I can't believe he said that. I can't
believe he said that.
I cannot believe he said that.
>> god. I can't believe he said that. Oh my
god.
>> I'm having difficulty processing that he
said that.
>> Imagine having the audacity to [__]
be like, yeah, I went to Iraq. I went to
Iraq and it's actually Islam that's the
biggest danger. You're the danger,
idiot.
You're a danger to your family.
>> What the [__]
>> Based. Love you.
>> What the [__] Isn't it Is this against
TOS?
Pretty sure. Didn't they Didn't they
pass Didn't they adopt new new TOS to um
the address the thing?
Do you mind linking the tweet? I have
some veteran pals who would absolutely
want to hear this.
>> maudlin
>> Maudlin, self-pitying or heartfeltly or
tearfully sentimental.
>> This uh yeah.
That is a crazy thing crazy thing to
say.
There you go. That's the tweet right
there.
wild you guys
>> And a danger to yourself, douchebag.
>> Nope, not one I've ever bumped into
before. Not one I've come across.
>> Oh man, I'm
Oh my god, you guys. Oh, that's getting
clipped. Well, I don't give a [__]
dude. Shut the [__] up. If you go to
Iraq and you learn that lesson, you
realize that that was wrong, you're
welcome here. You come back from Iraq
and you [__] talk about how this was
actually awesome and I [__] hate
Islam, then [__] you.
>> away with a maudlin appeal to decency by
invoking a story about some other guy
that isn't you, veteran or otherwise,
you'll sound just like Hutch.
>> Thank you for $10. Thank you.
>> You didn't learn anything. You're
goddamn cattle. You're sending other
people like you
>> Well, what did the guy actually say?
Hang on.
Um
Well, to be fair, the guy The guy he's
he's interacting with is kind of wilding
out about um Islam.
But nonetheless,
>> soy facing 10 [__] minutes about this
clip, Hutch finally goes and looks and
sees that this guy was talking crazy
[__] beforehand. Wow.
>> like this. I mean, this is that like you
know, nothing justifies that, right?
>> You're goddamn cattle. You're sending
other people like you to be in a similar
[__] predicament to yourself.
Whatever, [__] I'll start [__] live
streaming on YouTube tomorrow. Suck my
dick.
>> No, you're getting clipped.
>> By who? The people that have been
literally begging for American sons and
daughters to go and [__] die in Iran
for the last 2 weeks? By peo
>> Uh Twitch's strictest rules apply when
speech targets protected characteristics
such as race, religion,
sex, gender identity, sexual
orientation, disability, nationality.
Veteran or military service is not
listed as protected characteristic, so
insults towards veterans aren't
classified as hateful conduct.
Um it still may violate Twitch's
harassment abuse ab- abusive conduct
rules.
>> Such a [__] home on a day to day
>> Who gives a [__] bro?
I thought they passed a new TOS
policy because of the Frogan thing.
>> Um
PTSD
uh
That is for sure TOS. I mean, this is
for sure TOS. This is for sure TOS.
>> The people who keep going, "Yeah, based.
No, we got to give more money to
Israel."
Those people
Those people who are going to [__]
turn around and then now act as though
they give a [__]
about veterans?
The same people like Asmongold who
[__] celebrated when that Navy SEAL
>> Hutch, it's listed. Oh my god. What?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. All right. ChatGPT
got it wrong again, guys. There you go.
You beat ChatGPT.
Um Twitch aims to be Oh, this is their
hateful conduct policy. Oh, you know,
they added it. Yeah, for sure. Veteran
right there.
Twitch aims to be a place where everyone
can come together and share community
experiences. This vision is threatened
>> They didn't add it, it was already on
there before Frogan.
Just know what he's talking about.
>> When people experience harmful rhetoric
and abuse on Twitch, Twitch does not
permit behavior that is motivated
>> thing they added to TOS cuz of these
people was the stupid [__] Zionist as
a slur [__]
Or the or this scum white hearts like
the Oreo.
Road forward Ethan was supporting.
>> by hatred, prejudice, or intolerance.
Uh including behavior that promotes or
encourages discrimination, denigration,
harassment, or violence based on the
following protected characteristics:
race, ethnicity, color, cast,
national origin,
immigration status, religion, sex,
gender, gender identity, sexual
orientation, disability, serious medical
condition, that's another one right
there, PTSD, and veteran status.
Uh with his with his uniform had his
[__] arm broken?
Really?
I mean, to be To be clear, the guy the
guy that he pulled up was wilding out
about about um Islam, but you know,
why is every other veteran catching
strays here? You know what I mean?
That's just such a
>> Wasn't about every veteran, was it, you
[__] idiot?
>> brain went to inappropriate, but that's
not That doesn't cover it. I mean, this
is such This is such an This is such an
unacceptable thing to
>> appropriate.
>> say, man. You don't like That's
unbelievable.
It's [__] unbelievable.
You know, a lot of the A lot of the
people that signed up for the military,
like my buddy,
may he rest in peace,
he did that [__] I I you know, he did
that [__] mostly because he was lacking
direction
and
uh was struggling in school. Like he was
>> makes it all fine, then. Well, that
makes it all fine. Who cares if you
signed up to an illegal immoral uh war
to go and commit heinous acts in someone
else's country.
Uh if you are struggling in school, if
you you were struggling Yankoid school,
silly little Yankoid struggling in
school, better go shoot some brown kids
to figure out what's going on in your
life. Go and get your head straight by
shooting some brown kids.
The whole world A whole world just
exists for Americans to figure out their
lives.
That makes it all fine then, Hutch. I
guess he's immune from any criticism or
judgment. Your dead friend's immune from
any criticism or judgment cuz he he did
it to figure out his head, figure out
his life. What is the [__] argument
here? What is the [__] argument here,
dude?
>> Such a smart guy, but he was never a
good student.
And uh
you know, he needed he needed the GI
Bill. Like he needed he needed that
[__] And uh
>> I guess it's fine then.
>> And it's fine then because he wanted to
go over there and like [__] murder
people.
>> Well, if that was the case, Hutch, then
I'm sure he would have a very nuanced
intelligent take about the Iran
conflict, Islam, and his regrets from
the Iraq war. Wouldn't he? And as such,
Hassan wouldn't be addressing him in
this clip, as you would know
if you actually listened to the clip
instead of just crying about how your
friend got, you know, just randomly
happened upon an an IED. Just randomly
happened upon He was just going about
his daily life.
Just going about his daily life, living
a normal life, and he just there was
just an IED. There was just an IED. He
just walked into an IED. For no reason
at all.
>> Many, many such cases. Many such cases
as far as people that sign up for the
military. So, I don't know. This is such
an outrageous thing to say. That's what
we're doing. If Twitch can apply this
[__] double standard when one veteran
is getting their [__] arm
>> Classic unfortunate IED incident. That
happens, doesn't it, guys? You just
going about your normal civilian life,
and you walk into an IED.
We've all had that happen, haven't we?
>> broken by an American congressperson.
>> Sorry, wait. No, I I'm not an I'm not an
Iraqi child. Wait.
>> for opposing America waging Israel's
wars. When Twitch doesn't [__] ban
Asmongold for laughing at that and
saying, "Yeah, based." And that he
deserved it. When Twitch literally
doesn't say a single damn thing about
that, but then turns around and tries to
Well, did Asmon like
do targeted harassment against veterans?
Or did he just I mean, I don't Listen, I
I obviously don't [__] with Asmon.
But, it's entirely possible that what he
what Asmon said in that clip, whatever
he's referring to, was
um extremely distasteful and disgusting,
but not
>> When you When you slip on a banana peel
and accidentally sell yourself to the US
military, doesn't that always happen,
guys?
Doesn't that happen? We've all had that
happen, haven't we?
And you just want to You just, you know,
you slip on a banana peel in a comical
fashion, you go
falling back and sell yourself to the US
military.
Whoops.
>> Not technically a violation of TOS,
right?
Uh Oh my [__] god, Hasan talking
about a Twitch double standard is just
so [__] funny. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Ban me for this [__] [__] this
platform. I will never [__] come back
here.
Y'all are a bunch
>> Yes, he will. Yes, he will.
>> of dumb [__] [__] too, for being
like, "Oh, you're going to get clipped."
So out of bounds. Dumb [__]
doesn't even realize his own lived
experiences should have taught him a
very valuable lesson. What the [__] do
you know about his life experience, man?
>> What What he said in chat, he's an Iraq
war veteran.
>> What can you How could you possibly
You know,
sometimes, man, people just don't know
how to turn that [__] off and um
>> Why would you turn that [__] off on
stream?
Why would you turn off the inflammatory
uh uh you know, like
bombastic
passionate response off on stream. Why
would you do that, Hutch? Unless you
want it to be an SSRI outlet.
>> Guys, we can't judge them for leveling
the town. Don't you know they were a
troubled teenager? International law is
for other countries anyway.
>> Thank you, Spencer, for the $5. Thank
you.
Very true.